DANA PERINO AND GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS STANDING FIRM
ON HIS DECISION TO PULL THE PLUG
ON A WHITE HOUSE INVITATION FOR
THE SUPER BOWL CHAMPION
PHILADELPHIA EAGLES.
THE PRESIDENT INSTEAD POSTING A
CELEBRATION OF AMERICA EVENT.
>> WE LOVE OUR COUNTRY.
WE RESPECT OUR FLAG AND WE
PARLAY STAND FOR THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM.
IT'S ABOUT TIME THAT WE
UNDERSTOOD.
WE STAND TO HONOR OUR MILITARY
AND TO HONOR OUR COUNTRY AND TO
REMEMBER THE FALLEN HEROES WHO
NEVER MADE IT BACK HOME.
>> Kimberly: AFTER THE TEAM
WAS DISINVITED, THE PHILADELPHIA
MAYOR SLAMMED THE PRESIDENT IS
"NOT A TRUE PATRIOT" AND
LAUNCHED A NEW PERSONAL ATTACK.
>> THE GUY IS A SCARY GUY.
I DON'T -- HOPEFULLY BY THE TIME
HE IS GONE, WE CAN RECOVER FROM
THIS MESS.
BUT THIS IS A BAD TIME IN OUR
I'M FRIGHTENED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT HE HAS HIS HANDS IN THE
NUCLEAR CODES, THAT HE THREATENS
TO ANNIHILATE NORTH KOREA.
>> Kimberly: MEANWHILE.
SHAKING MY HEAD.
MEANWHILE, THE WHITE HOUSE IS
ACCUSING THE EAGLES OF PLAYING
POLITICS.
>> THIS WASN'T A POLITICAL STUNT
BY THE EAGLES FRANCHISE, THEN
THEY WOULD NOT PLAN TO ATTEND
THE EVENT AND HAVE BACKED OUT OF
THE LAST MINUTE.
IF IT WASN'T A POLITICAL STUNT,
THEY WOULDN'T HAVE ATTEMPTED TO
RESCHEDULE THE VISIT WHEN THEY
KNEW THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS
GOING TO BE OVERSEAS.
IF THIS WASN'T A POLITICAL
STUNT, THEY WOULDN'T HAVE WAITED
UNTIL MONDAY.
>> Kimberly: JESSE IS A
DIE-HARD EAGLES FAN AND HE WAS
THERE FOR ALL THE ACTION AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
HEY, JESSE.
>> HEY, KAMIL E.
>> Kimberly: HOW ARE YOU
FEELING ABOUT THIS?
I KNOW YOU ARE A HUGE EAGLES
FAN.
>> HUGE FAN.
LET'S GET ONE THING STRAIGHT.
BOTH ARE WINNERS.
THE EAGLES BEAT THE PATRIOTS AND
TRUMP BEAT CRICKET HILLARY.
WE HAVE THAT.
NO ONE IS GOING TO TAKE IT AWAY
FROM US.
IT'S TOUGH FOR ME.
EAGLES, TRUMP.
I AM A PHILLY GUY.
I'M GOING TO HAVE TO SIDE WITH
TRUMP.
THE EAGLES TRIED A TRICK PLAY,
TRUMP SNIFFED IT OUT AND SHOW
DOWN.
I DON'T LIKE THE GAMESMANSHIP
WITH THE GUEST LIST.
IT WAS LESS THAN TEN PEOPLE.
IT WAS LIKE OWNER, ASSISTANT
COACH AND MASCARA.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE MAYOR
COMING IN.
HE DOESN'T SPEAK FOR THE
PHILADELPHIA EAGLES.
HE SOUNDS LIKE JOY BEHAR.
THE GUY IS A JOKE.
WHAT MESSAGE THIS COUNTRY IN?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THIS GUY IS
TALKING TO.
EVERYBODY WAS HAPPY TO BE THERE.
THEY DIDN'T SEE THE EAGLES.
THEY SAW ME.
I WAS KIND OF THE CONSOLATION
PRIZE.
ALTHOUGH ONE PERSON THOUGHT I
WAS TED MOSBY.
I DON'T REALLY KNOW WHO THAT IS.
ANOTHER PERCENTILE I WAS
TUCKER CARLSON.
>> Kimberly: WOW.
YOU ARE REALLY WINNING OVER
THERE.
BIG DAY, HUGE DAY FOR JESSE.
THAT'S FINE.
BRIAN, YOU WANT TO CHIME IN?
>> Brian: JESSE, IF WE ARE
UNDERSTAND THIS ABOUT THE EAGLES
DIDN'T SHOW.
THEY MADE IT CLEAR LATE LAST
WEEK THEY WERE GOING TO SHOP.
THEY TRIED TO TRUMP TRUMP.
WHEN TRUMP PULLED THE RUG OUT
FROM THEM FROM WITHIN THE
ATTACKS CAME.
WHO IS THE WINNER?
I DON'T GET IT.
>> Jesse: LIKE I SAID, THEY
ARE BOTH WINNERS.
THE EAGLES HAVE THE TROPHY.
THAT'S NEVER GOING TO CHANGE.
TRUMP DOES WHAT HE DOES.
HE DID THE SINGAPORE DANCE WITH
LITTLE ROCKET MAN CANCELING THE
MEETING AND THEN BRINGING IT
BACK ON.
THE EAGLES DON'T LOOK AT HERE
BUT PHILADELPHIA FANS, I DON'T
REALLY THINK THEY ARE GOING TO
CARE VERY MUCH.
WE ARE STILL GOING TO CHEER FOR
THE EAGLES.
THE TRUMP PEOPLE IN PENNSYLVANIA
ARE STILL GOING TO PULL THE
LEVER FOR DONALD.
>> Kimberly: HERE WE GO.
SUPPORTED HER NEEDS NEWS AT
NIGHT.
>> Juan: I AM DEEPLY OFFENDED.
NOBODY SAID HEY, AREN'T YOU
JUAN WILLIAMS?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: NO, JUAN.
I DID NOT HAPPEN.
>> Juan: YOU NOY PULLING YOUR
LEG.
LAST WEEK, THE NFL OWNERS SAID
THEY WERE SETTING NEW RULES FOR
THIS COMING SEASON TO REQUIRE
THE PLAYER SITTING FOR THE
ANTHEM WILL REMAIN IN THE
LOCKER ROOM.
THIS MORNING HE IS TWEETING OUT
NO ESCAPE TO THE LOCKER ROOM.
THE OWNERS AREN'T EVEN ESCAPING.
TRUMP IS BULLYING THE PLAYERS
AND THE OWNERS, AM I WRONG?
>> Jesse: I THINK BULLYING IS
A TOUGH TERM, JUAN.
I THINK WE ALL NEED TO GROW UP
AND STOP BEING SO SENSITIVE
ABOUT BULLYING HERE.
THESE ARE BILLIONAIRE OWNERS
MAKING A FORTUNE.
I THINK EVERYBODY IS A GROWN UP
HERE.
HE DIDN'T LIKE THIS KIND OF IN
BETWEEN DEAL WHERE YOU GET TO
STAY IN THE LOCKER ROOM FOR THE
ANTHEM OR YOU'RE GOING TO COME
OUT AND STAND.
HE WANTS IT ALL IN.
YOU'RE EITHER 100% FOR THE
COUNTRY AND THE FLAG, OR WE ARE
NOT GOING TO PLAY BALL.
HE'S GOING TO FIGHT UNTIL HE IS
SATISFIED THAT AND WE WILL SEE
WHO BACKS DOWN.
SEEMED LIKE THE OWNERS BACKED
DOWN A LITTLE BIT.
>> Kimberly: JESSE, ANY MORE
HIGHLIGHTS FROM THE DAY?
>> Jesse: I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS
BECAUSE WHEN I WAS TRYING TO
TALK TO THE PRESIDENT WHEN HE
WAS LEAVING, I DIDN'T GET A
CHANCE TO.
I LOST MY DAD FOR A SECOND, WHO
I BROUGHT.
I CAUGHT BACK UP WITH HIM AND I
SAID DAD, WHERE WERE YOU?
HE GOES, I JUST DID AN INTERVIEW
WITH ABC.
AND I'M LIKE, WAS A LOCAL ABC?
HE GOES I DON'T KNOW.
IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN NATIONAL.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT MY DAD SAID
ON CAMERA TO ABC.
I THINK HE IS JEALOUS THAT MOM
TEXTS HAVE TAKEN OFF.
>> Kimberly: I THINK YOUR DAD
SHOULD GET AN AGENT NEXT, RIGHT?
I DON'T KNOW.
I'M GLAD YOU GUYS FOUND EACH
OTHER.
BUDDY SYSTEM AND ALL.
SOUNDS LIKE IT WAS FUN.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO SAY
GOODBYE NOW, PARTING IS SUCH
SWEET SORROW, JESSE.
GET BACK TO WINNING.
>> Brian: HOW COME PEOPLE SAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD HAVE
HAPPENED ANYWAY.
HE HAS THE MASCOT, THE OWNER,
WHO HATES HIM, DESPISES HIM,
SINCE HE'S DESTROYING THE
COUNTRY.
ONE OTHER PLAYER PERHAPS.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN HE'S GOING TO
HAVE IT?
HOW COULD HE POSSIBLY HAVE IT?
HE HAD NO CHOICE BUT TO CANCEL
IT.
>> Juan: THAT'S NOT TRUE.
HE HAD ISSUED AN INVITATION.
THE POINT IS THAT THE PLAYERS
DIDN'T WANT TO BE USED AS, LIKE,
THEY WANTED TO HAVE A REAL -- I
THINK THEY REQUESTED TIME WITH
TRUMP.
THEY WERE TOLD NO.
>> Brian: THEY WERE NOT TOLD
NO.
THE REQUEST WAS WITH 85 REQUESTS
FOR INVITATIONS AND PRESS
CREDENTIALS.
YOU KNOW THE PHOTO OP DESIGN
THAT HAS BEEN DONE.
>> Juan: THEY DON'T WANT A
PHOTO UP.
THIS IS SOMETHING ONE OF THE
FORMER PLAYERS SAID.
IT WASN'T JUST ABOUT THE
STANDING.
A LOT OF THESE GUYS DON'T LIKE
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Kimberly: DANA, LET'S TALK
ABOUT HOW THIS PLAYED OUT.
PEOPLE EXPECTING THIS FUN, HAPPY
THING.
AND YOU HAVE THE MAYOR WHO
SOUNDED KIND OF CRAZY.
>> Dana: CAN I SAY I THINK THE
WHOLE THING, ALL OF IT IS A REAL
SHAME.
I DON'T LIKE CULTURE WAR STUFF.
I THINK THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
SUCH GOOD NEWS TO TALK ABOUT.
THEY LEAD THE WHITE HOUSE
BRIEFING TODAY TO TALK ABOUT THE
ECONOMY WHICH IS ROARING.
THEN THEY HAVE ALL THE STUFF.
CULTURAL STUFF WILL ALWAYS RISE
TO THE TOP.
IT WILL GET COVER THE MOST.
I DO THINK IT'S A SHAME.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW MORE THE
DETAILS BECAUSE I THINK SOME OF
THE FACTS, AS I UNDERSTAND THEM,
ARE IN DISPUTE.
IF THEY WANT TO HAVE A PERSONAL
MEETING BEHIND-THE-SCENES?
WE DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW.
YOU SAID THEY DIDN'T.
>> Brian: THEY REQUESTED IT.
I DON'T KNOW THEY WERE DENIED.
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK IT'S A SHAME.
IT'S POSSIBLE MAYBE ONE OF THE
BEST THINGS TO DO IS JUST TO
STOP HAVING TEENS COME TO THE
WHITE HOUSE AND FOCUS ON THE
PEOPLES BUSINESS.
>> Kimberly: GREG, WHERE DO
YOU FALL?
>> Greg: I DON'T GIVE A TOSS
ABOUT THESE PLAYERS.
I AM ALL HERE TO TALK ABOUT IT
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT
IT.
THE ECONOMY IS GOOD.
LOW UNEMPLOYMENT.
WHERE IS ISIS RIGHT NOW?
NORTH KOREA IS AT THE TABLE.
WE HAVE IRAN ON WATCH.
WE HAVE SO MUCH GOOD NEWS.
I REALLY DON'T CARE THAT THESE
PLAYERS ARE UPSET OR OFFENDED.
I DON'T CARE.
THEY ARE MILLIONAIRES.
THE OWNERS ARE BILLIONAIRES.
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO DO, SEE
TRUMP DO IS MAYBE DO A DRILLING
INITIATIVE TO DEAL WITH THE GAS
PRICES.
THAT WOULD BE GOOD.
THE MEDIA HAS CARRIED THE WATER
ON THIS AND MADE IT A TERRIBLE
STORY.
THE CLAIMANT IS NOT DIRECTED AT
THE ANTHEM COLLEGES GOING
AGAINST OUR EYES.
WHEN YOU'RE WATCHING A FOOTBALL
GAME.
YOU CAN SAY IT'S ABOUT POLICE
BRUTALITY BEAVER WE'RE WATCHING
IT HAPPEN DURING THE ANTHEM.
THE ANTHEM IS A POLITICAL ACT.
STANDING FOR THE ANTHEM IS A
POLITICAL ACT.
SO IS THE FOURTH OF JULY, SO WAS
THE FLAG.
THAT IS GARBAGE.
IT'S JUST A SYMBOL.
SAYING IT IS A FREE-SPEECH ISSUE
COMMITS ONLY FREE-SPEECH IF IT
IS PERTAINING TO THE GOVERNMENT.
THIS IS AN ACTUAL BUSINESS.
YOU ARE NOT GETTING ARRESTED FOR
SAYING SOMETHING.
YOU ARE JUST BEING, YOU'RE BEING
PENALIZED AS AN EMPLOYEE.
THE WAY THE MEDIA HAS CURATED,
AND HE SIGHED SPECIFICALLY IN
THE PRESS CONFERENCE IN WHICH
APRIL RYAN AND THE OTHER DUDE
FROM NBC OR PEPPERING SANDERS
WITH REDUNDANT, STUPID QUESTIONS
LIKE AREN'T YOU AWARE THIS IS
ABOUT BRUTALITY?
AREN'T YOU AWARE THE MESSAGES
CONVOLUTED?
WHEN YOU SEE PLAYERS UP THERE,
THEY ARE MAKING -- THERE'S
KNEELING DURING THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM, THEY ARE MAKING
A HUGE MISTAKE.
THEY ARE INJECTING POLITICS INTO
A NONPOLITICAL EVENT.
WE TALK ABOUT THIS EVERY YEAR.
WE TALK ABOUT THE BEST WAY TO
RUIN A THANKSGIVING DINNER IS TO
TALK ABOUT POLITICS.
SOMEHOW IT'S DIFFERENT AT A
SPORTING EVENT?
NO.
YOU INJECT POLITICS AT AN
APPROPRIATE VENUE.
YOU PAY THE PRICE.
WE ARE SO OVER THIS.
MOVE ON.
>> Juan: LET ME TELL YOU HOW
IMPORTANT THIS IS.
IT'S ABOUT CULTURE WARS, AS DANA
SAID.
IT'S PARTICULARLY DANGEROUS
BECAUSE IT TEARS OF THE FABRIC
OF OUR SOCIETY WITH REGARD TO
RACE.
>> Greg: I AGREE.
BUT YOU SEE EVERYTHING THROUGH
THE PRISM OF RACE.
>> Juan: I DO NOT.
I HAVE NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT
MAJORITY OF THE COLOR OF THE
PLAYERS, THE ONES KNEELING AND
RAISING A FIST BECAUSE OF
PROTESTING BRUTALITY.
LET ME EXPLAIN.
IN FACT, THE RULING OUT OF THE
FLAG AND THE ANTHEM WITH THE
PLAYERS ON THE SIDELINES IS A
NEW REALITY.
IT USED TO BE THAT THEY WERE
ALWAYS IN THE LOCKER ROOM DURING
THE PLAYING OF THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM.
NOW THEY ARE ON THE SIDELINES.
IN RECENT YEARS, THERE'S BEEN AN
EXPLOSION, BIG FLAGS, FLYOVERS.
IN SO MANY CASES, IN FACT WHAT
YOU SEE IS THAT THE NFL WAS
CHARGING THE MILITARY.
>> Greg: WE ARE VEERING OFF TO
ANOTHER --
I WANT TO AGREE WITH YOU, JUAN.
>> Juan: POLITICS AND SPORTS
IS IMPORTANT IN AMERICA TODAY.
>> Greg: I WANT TO AGREE ON
THIS.
THERE ARE ISSUES WITH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM BUT THIS
SPECIFIC DEBATE DID NOTHING TO
HELP THE DIALOGUE.
INSTEAD HE CREATED TWO SEPARATE
TEAMS.
PRO ANTHEM AND ANTI-ANTHEM.
WHEN YOUR EYES LOOK AT SOMETHING
IT HAPPEN, VISUALS ARE THE MOST
PERSUADABLE THING.
PEOPLE SEE IT DID NOTHING FOR
THE DIALOGUE.
ALIENATED SPORTS FANS.
IF YOU BELIEVE STANDING FOR THE
ANTHEM OR THE FLAG IS A
POLITICAL EVENT, THAT'S ON YOU
FOR BEING POLITICAL.
>> Juan: I STAND FOR THE
ANTHEM MYSELF BUT I'M TELLING
YOU THAT WHAT YOU'VE GOT HERE IS
A SITUATION WHERE DONALD TRUMP
HAS FOUND A WAY TO STIR HIS
BASE.
HIS BASE IS SAYING -- THIS HAS
NOTHING TO DO THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM, NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE FLAG.
NOTHING TO DO WITH LOVE OF OUR
TROOPS.
>> Kimberly: YES, IT DOES.
>> Juan: THE NFL
PLAYERS ASSOCIATION SAID WE LOVE
OUR TROOPS.
WE LOVE OUR COUNTRY.
WE LOVE OUR FLAG.
>> Greg: WHY DID THEY HAVE TO
DO THAT?
THE MESSAGE IS CONVOLUTED.
>> Brian: THEY DON'T LIKE
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY ARE STANDING UP, THEY SAY
IT'S POLICE BRUTALITY.
>> Juan: BAD COPS, NOT GOOD
COMPS.
>> Kimberly: THEY HAD TO PUT
THAT STATEMENT OUT BECAUSE IT
WAS PERCEIVED, DISRESPECTFUL.
YES, IT IS.
>> Juan: PUSHED BY
DONALD TRUMP TO STIR UP VOTERS.
>> Kimberly: HE WASN'T THE ONE
TAKING A KNEE.
>> Brian: HE WASN'T PRESENT
WHEN IT STARTED.
-- HE WASN'T PRESIDENT WHEN IT
STARTED.
HERE'S THE THING.
THE PRESIDENT'S COMMITTEE WANTS
TO TALK ABOUT THE ECONOMY COME
HE CAN LAY OUT WHAT HE WANTS TO.
HE HAS NOT TAKEN ON KIM.
IF YOU WANTED TO TALK ABOUT THE
ECONOMY, HE JUST WOULDN'T TWEET
ABOUT THIS.
HE WANTS THIS FIGHT.
>> Juan: YES, HE DOES.
>> Juan: HE WANTS TO TELL
>> Juan: HE WANTS TO TELB
>> Juan: HE WANTS TO TELA
>> Juan: HE WANTS TO TELK
>> Juan: HE WANTS TO TELP
>> Juan: HE WANTS TO TELO
>> Juan: HE WANTS TO TELL
>> Juan: HE WANTS TO TELE
>> Juan: HE WANTS TO TELT
>> Juan: HE WANTS TO TELO
SHUT UP.
>> Kimberly: LOOK AT THE
RECORD UNEMPLOYMENT AMONG BLACKS
AND MINORITIES AND WOMEN RIGHT
NOW.
THAT IS SOMEBODY WHO REALLY
WANTS TO TELL BLACK PEOPLE TO
SHUT UP.
[ALL SPEAKING]
>> Juan: ARGUMENTS LIKE THAT,
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE FAX.
OH, MY GOD.
>> Kimberly: THIS IS
RIDICULOUS.
>> Brian: CHRIS LONG, WHAT
COLOR IS HE?
>> Juan: STEVE KERR, ALSO A
WHITE GUY.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE FLAG.
HE'S USING THIS TO ATTACK A
MINORITY GROUP.
>> Kimberly: NO.
HE'S USING THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTACK THE
PRESIDENT TO TRY TO CALL HIM
RACIST, TO SAY HE IS AGAINST
BLACK PEOPLE WHEN THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE TO SUGGEST THAT
WHATSOEVER.
>> Juan: THE NFL IS ONE OF THE
MOST INCLUSIVE WORKPLACES IN
AMERICA BUT NOW AS A RESULT OF
TRUMP'S INTERFERENCE, IT HAS
CORRODED THE RELATIONSHIP.
>> Kimberly: THE WHOLE THING.
I THINK THE NFL IS JUST FINE.
TEAMS ARE STANDING BY THEIR
PLAYERS.
TO TRY TO TYPE THIS INTO
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND CALL HIM A
RACIST AND THAT HE WANTS TO TELL
BLACK PEOPLE TO SHUT UP IS JUST
COMPLETELY OUT OF LINE.
>> Brian: IF THE POLITICO
STORY IS TRUE, IT LOOKS LIKE A
SCRIPTED EVENT TO EMBARRASS THE
PRESIDENT.
GIVE ME 85 PASSIVE, 70 PASSES,
THE MASCOT AND THE OWNER.
IT'S A SCRIPTED ATTEMPT TO
EMBARRASS THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Juan: WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THE
PLAYERS SHOW UP AND TRUMPED
STAN'S PARENTS IS THESE GUYS ARE
SUPPORTING ME.
PLEASE.
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE USED.
>> Kimberly: WHY DID THEY SAY
80 ARE GOING TO COME AND THEN
MAY PULL -- IT'S LIKE A BAIT AND
SWITCH.
HE SHOWS UP AND THERE'S THE
GOOFY MASCOT AND POOR JESSE AND
HIS DAD.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHY THIS IS SO